under the previous employment section of
his CV my next question is Soldier
Diplomat charity CEO award-winning
travel writer Harvard professor and most
recently Britain's top podcaster but his
role as politician at the subject of his
new book Politics on the edge which
records in full uncensored fashion the
complete omnis shambles at the heart of
our British political system we're
making his own censored debut I am
genuinely delighted to have probably the
most liked politician in Britain but the
bar is low Rory is doing
that because you've you've the politics
many people a lot of my family
um wish you had wish you were right in
the front line of the thing why did you
eventually just say I'm just done with
this I I I met the end with Boris
Johnson I mean that was the end for me
and I I'd you know put in a good nine
years I've been a cabinet minister I'd
um I liked Theresa May I thought she was
trying to do the right thing but I
really thought that Boris Johnson was a
dangerous thing I thought he was a
shambolic clown I thought he was going
to be very damaging for our constitution
yeah I mean that's exactly how he turned
out to be I mean you were very prescient
in your assessment of him which led you
to leave I guess the problem is if
people like you don't want to stay in
our system it's never going to improve
it's a difficult balance isn't it it's a
really difficult balance you you put up
with a lot you work out how much you can
put up with and at some point you have
to be like enough's enough you I mean
you're you're quite direct about some of
our former leaders of Theresa May she
had some of the monarchs stiff Authority
not necessarily a negative I guess David
Cameron later in Cabool you really came
across like a hosted a pheasant shoot
rented only for the day courtesy
presiding whether any particular desire
to know about the detail of the soil on
which he was standing or about the
professionals whose job it was was to
drive the game I mean a real picture of
superficiality there from that prime
minister yeah I I thought that um when I
came in that one of the things that
struck me first and it's probably
something you see a lot in the public
sees a lot is fundamentally a lack of
seriousness
it really has become like a massive
campaigning Communications game
and there isn't any time really to talk
about policy you would have thought that
secretly they might take their masks off
and they get around the cabinet table
and they're like okay enough with going
out to the media what do we really think
about this but it happens so rarely I
mean
the worst five miles of all your stories
it might be the worst thing I've read in
a long time Liz truss and you write this
back in London Liz truss asked me how my
weekend had been I explained that my
father had died she pulls for a moment
nodded and asks where my 25-year
environment plan will be ready
I read that and I thought I can't
believe I'm reading them and I thought
actually Yes actually I can believe I'm
reading that because this trust always
exuded in there to me of somebody who
probably would behave like that yeah
without a shred of decency or basic
Humanity no no I I mean I I think she's
um she she's a very unique human being I
I had a I worked for lestrasse I worked
for pre Patel I worked for Boris Johnson
and it was a real education but that
moment yeah although that was very sad
for me I mean obviously I love my father
deeply of course and I was um but I
think that's that's what that's more
awkwardness I think she's somebody who
that's not awkward that's just a total
lack of basic humanity and manners I
think she's somebody who doesn't
relate very easily to other people and
maybe that's maybe I'm psychologizing
too much but yeah Richardson you call
Machiavellian what why do you call him
that I think probably because I sensed I
I used to sit next to the library's big
kind of wooden library and he was my
library partner so it's quite fond of
him
um but I didn't quite
get why he'd suddenly gone hard for
brexit and particularly even when I got
around that and I understand many of my
friends voted brexit I couldn't get
around him getting in behind Boris
Johnson so hard because he'd seemed to
me quite a thoughtful serious he seems
the kind of serious guy you're talking
about yeah he doesn't if I was if I was
talking to him which I'd do occasionally
the brexit thing I didn't understand why
he would be supportive and I agree about
Boris I guess I guess if Boris is the
leader you either fall in behind or you
do what you did and just get out of it
right but he he fell in behind pretty
quickly yeah the reason I found it
difficult is that it was the MPS who
made it possible for Boris because if
you remember in this leadership contest
you needed the MPS to vote for him first
and basically there were a whole middle
group of MPS and you'd say to them
we know him very well we've worked for
them I'd worked with them in the foreign
office we know that he doesn't really
pay attention we know he's pretty
careless about a lot of stuff you don't
really think he'd be a good prime
minister do you and they'd say no so so
why are you supporting him and they'd
say because he's going to win
but hasn't politics always been
full of charlatans and unprincipled
people and if we accept that that's a
bitter reality not all I've met some
very decent people in politics actually
um but it's not entirely surprising that
people like Boris Johnson Donald Trump
and others in a televisual age the ones
who can crack a joke and make people
laugh you have a little bit less of the
robot about them and people thought
Theresa May was robotic it's not
entirely surprising that they rise to
the top and have a constituent that will
support that no it's not surprising
politics always had charlatans and
bluffers and I think we people like me
from the kind of center of ground of
politics have a lot to answer for 2008
financial crisis showed that we'd
mismanaged the economy I think Iraq and
Afghanistan were horrible foreign policy
humiliations and so I think people like
Trump or Johnson are
responding to a genuine public anger
these guys screwed up they didn't know
what they were doing the problem is what
people are choosing to do is throw them
like a hand grenade at the system
but I mean in Trump's case it's
effective
he just tears up any rules that have
gone before he doesn't care and he has a
constituent audience that don't really
care what he does or what he says yeah I
think it's true person but I I think
that
to counter that there's always going to
be people like Donald Trump or Boris
Johnson around what's lacking is the
seriousness and the kind of middle ranks
of politics and that's why I think the
system feels so broken what do we do
about it how do we fix it I think we
have to decentralize we have to take
power out of Westminster I'm very
excited by you know the mayor of
Manchester mayor of West Midlands Street
and I think we've got to get out of this
Victorian idea that a bunch of amateurs
sitting in Parliament are going to be
able to micromanage the country you were
a tutor to Prince William and Prince
Harry
so what do you feel about what's
happened with those two so I I don't
talk about it I know that's why I've
asked you yes it's one thing the show's
called uncensored come on here and start
self-censoring what's the matter with
your mouth I think if I'm teaching them
like but it's on a human level at them
confidentiality I like them both very
much with a lovely voice do you feel sad
about what's happened they they now hate
each other so much they don't even talk
to each other I definitely feel sad yeah
as far as you're going to go as far as
I'm going to go who was who was the
brighter
are you with a tutor as far as I'm gonna
go that's not my job from a military
perspective when I watch Harry doing his
Invictus games thing I think good on you
when I think about his service to his
country I think good on him yeah you
know my brother-in-law taught them both
at Sanders actually
um I thought they were both good
soldiers
um when I see him the other half of him
running around the world trashing his
family and the monarchy and everything I
can't stand it yeah I I I sympathize a
lot of what you're saying I'm a big
supporter for the king I'm a big
supporter of the Prince of Wales I'm
very proud of the royal family and I
think that's very very sad should he
stick to stuff like the Invictus games
and just shut up trash in the Royals I'm
staying out of this month he effectively
just you just said you agree no I agree
with a lot of things as his former tutor
I understand
dragging me too deep you'll sell some
books here Rory but a bit of uncensored
honesty let's take a break I want to
talk to you after break it's 9 11
anniversary today and I want to ask
where you were when it happened but also
it prompted you to go on this
extraordinary two-year walk through
Afghanistan and other countries I want
to know why you did that what you
learned what we should all learn perhaps
from that period that's after the break
I'm back with Rory Stewart here the
uniquely popular and liked British
political figure
um Louis rubial is I wanted to ask you
about that because it's everyone's
talking about this this guy and you've
managed to get an interview with him yes
so I've got a big interview with him
airing tomorrow night we got the first
interview and it was very interesting he
was very open very Frank about it he
said I was an idiot I shouldn't have
done it what do you feel though about
him potentially facing a criminal
prosecution now for the kiss
um I actually quite sympathized to the
lady at the end there Grace who was
saying that
um it's quite possible that the woman at
the time might not really have felt very
much but that afterwards you can feel
very very disturbed I mean look I it's
very difficult to judge
Spain different mores different cultures
but
I think you've got to be pretty careful
about that kind of thing yeah it's an
interesting sign at the time that it's
created such a fuel reaction
911 it's the 20 second anniversary uh
today of 9 11. I remember where I was I
was lying on a sofa recovering from back
surgery and was supposed to be lying
there for three weeks it was about eight
days in I got a call from a Daily Mirror
Newsroom I was the editor I got straight
in my car and drove to Canary wharfs not
even thinking that that might be a
Target itself it was the most
extraordinary day of my career and
obviously horrendous in so many ways
where were you when it happened I was
walking across Asia I'd been walking for
about a year and a bit and I didn't
understand what had happened
I was I met a guy sort of
probably
a couple of days after 9 11. and he
started trying to explain to me in
Nepali
said you know it's this Tower in America
and this plane hit at night so this guy
was crazy I literally you hadn't you had
no awareness of it at all processing
these words but I was like it's like
he's telling me there's been some sci-fi
attack in New York so it wasn't until
the 18th of September I was arrested and
accused of being an Al-Qaeda activist up
on the uh Tibetan Nepali you are the
least likely Al-Qaeda activist I'd
probably ever met so that's what I said
I said to the policeman I said I'm not a
friend like Cleo and he said that's
exactly why I think you are it was like
inspectorclusive
the walk that you were on and you
carried on for a long time you did two
years in the end it's an extraordinary
thing to do to Just Walk and Walk and
Walk and Walk what was the motivation
for that I had been a brief Liberty
Soldier than I was a diplomat and I felt
that I was locked behind these Embassy
balls and we were getting involved in
these other countries we had no idea
what was happening
so I walked across Afghanistan just
after 9 11. I walked through the winter
of December January February March just
the Taliban government fell and it was
changed my life changed me as a
politician changed me as a diplomat
because I saw the gap between these
Villages I was in where women had not
been more than two hours walked in
evolution their lives where I could see
drugs being traded people with guns and
then I turn up in Afghanistan in Kabul
and I hear the British government the
American government saying every Afghan
wants a gender sensitive multi-ethnic
centralized State based on Democracy
human rights the root of Law and I
thought I can't even translate that into
language they understand so
my life was changed I mean 911 was a
horrible event but it defined the next
10 years of my life I was in Afghanistan
I was in Iraq I was working to advise
the US government and I was trying to
stand up against what I saw as The
Madness of how people were responding
when you see what's going on in
Afghanistan now with the Taliban just
obviously taking back full control and
oppressing women again in their Millions
terrible poverty
what is the answer I mean Tobias elbow
got into hot water for it was a very
clumsy video he put out but the central
message we should start engaging again
with the Taliban did you have some
sympathy with that I did have sympathy
with that because the truth is that when
we sanction people like the Taliban we
don't change their behavior they're not
trying to go shopping inherents all you
end up doing is punishing the Afghan
people these are some of the poorest
people in the world very very difficult
to feed themselves over the winter
people selling their own organs to feed
themselves so I think we can find ways
of providing assistance to the Afghans
without going through the government and
sanctioning the government just makes
the area poorer and more unstable and
when you look at Ukraine there's a
growing sentiment amongst some
Republicans to my surprise in America
that America should yank the support
spend it at home not on this latest
foreign conflict what's your view of of
what's happening there I mean do you
think Ukraine can win is it incumbent on
the west to ensure they can win how far
do we get involved I fear that Ukraine
is getting like the Iran Iraq war which
dragged on for eight years I think we're
underestimating Russia's depth and
strength in the nationalistic sentiment
I think it's going to be very difficult
for Ukraine to break through the front
lines and even if they do
I don't think Russia's going away and I
think the threat to Putin isn't from the
left it's from the right
you tell a story in your book of house
and MP you thought about killing
yourself or the story of your
constituents trousers that went viral if
you have an interview where he says some
of the farmers the more remote parts of
constituency hold their trousers up with
twine he got picked up and he's accused
of being a pot you are of being
repository who thinks his vote is a
country bumpkins yeah it's it's a it's a
strange thing looking back at it over 12
years I can see now that I was
completely overreacting
what I'm trying to be honest about I
suppose is there's a new MP coming in
you feel
a very special relationship with your
constituent side is very proud of
Cumbria I was very proud of the work I
was doing I said a stupid thing to a
journalist and suddenly
it looks like I'm slagging off my own
constituents and
I really felt everything had ended I
sort of felt it's extraordinary that you
would feel it so deeply and how close
did you come to to acting on that
impulse um it's the only time in my life
I have felt like that I was I was
walking down the street and I saw a
Lamppost and I thought maybe I should
hang myself in slampers are you serious
yeah it was it was very it's the only
time in my life but it was
and I think it shows something because
you felt you'd broken that Bond of trust
with the constituents it probably I you
know I
I think a lot of this is about the way
that you exaggerate relationships with
people but I felt that an MP were their
constituents
it's like a a priest or a doctor you
have a very
special relationship and that if you
break it you're breaking your vocation
you know I mean I read it it was a
startling thing to read
I have to say though in the context of
the point you're trying to make
I do want more politicians to feel that
seriousness about that Bond of trust
with the electorate because if you don't
have that if you treat the electorate
with the kind of casual triviality that
Boris Johnson did or the recklessness
that is trusted or whatever I think if
you do that democracy slowly starts to
die and if we don't have a strong
democracy in this country I don't know
what we're left with
thank you and I think what I'm trying to
do in the book in in politics on the
edges to show yes a bit of humor but
above all to demonstrate that there is a
big big problem that this is no way to
run a government and that we need to
reform we need to reform our electoral
system we need to reform ministers going
in and out every couple of months out of
their jobs to have a serious country and
you know what else we need Rory we need
you back in the game you may not want to
do it but actually I think you should
thank you you going to
uh I think it just made you think about
it I think no it has made me think about
it more and it's made me think that
probably the way back in maybe is more
local as I say I'm very envious of mass
I thought about running to be an
independent yeah for mayor of London and
that's still something I think about a
lot
Politics on the edge it's a fascinating
it's actually a pretty scary book
actually because you lift the lid off
what we all fear is lying underneath in
our parliamentary system and it's got to
evolve and it's got to change we need
more people with your intellect and
seriousness I think
than we currently have and that would
help enormously Rory thank you thank you
for being uncensored